my talk is called theory of neuro
networks and the alternate title would
be deep learning without frameworks
because I'm going to be talking I'm
gonna be talking about the basics of
deep learning and neural networks but
I'm not gonna be using any framework so
I'm not gonna be using a Karass or
tensor flow and the whole point of this
talk is to hopefully help you guys
understand how deep learning and neural
networks were kind of under the hood
because usually when you're working with
these things you're gonna use a
framework that kind of hides a lot of
implementation so hopefully after this
talk even if you're you're completely
new to deep learning and neural networks
you'll have a better understanding of
how how those things work and so the
first part of my talk I'm going to be
going over some of the basic concepts
and showing how things work and then I
have a second part after lunch where I'm
gonna bring it all together and do some
live coding and show you how to solve an
actual problem using just just straight
Python and showing you how to create a
neural network from scratch so first a
little bit about me let me get my there
we go so my name is Bo Carnes like you
heard and I am from the United States
I'm from the state of Michigan and I
currently work at free code camp org
it's a non-profit with the goal of
providing a free curriculum for people
learning software development and so
anybody can go on and learn for free so
I like a new thing that we're doing over
at free code camp is we've translated
the curriculum into five different world
languages and we just use the Google
automatic translatable automatic
translator but we we are an open source
community so we're trying to get people
to go in that are native speakers and
fix the automatic translations and
Russian is one of the languages
so if anybody's interested in trying to
help out this open-source community and
you speak Russian you can go in and help
with the translation besides that I also
have made some courses for this book
publishing company called Manning
publications I saw on the the booth out
there I saw some Manning publications
books and I've created some video
courses so I have one called
algorithms in motion and then grokking
deep learning in motion so the second
one is kind of the grokking deep
learning in motion that's what this talk
is based off of and the whole course I
mean the whole video course is actually
based on this great book by another
author named Andrew Trask so so this I
would highly recommend this book for
anybody trying to learn deep learning so
my my whole my video course is based on
the book and this talk is based on the
course so let's kind of get into it here
Oh first of all I wanted to tell you
that I do it and so this is my personal
website Karnes @cc and then I made a
site page called Moscow so all my my
slides are on there and all the code
that I'm gonna be going over the during
this part of the talk and the second
part of the talk so you don't
necessarily need to look at it now but
if you ever want to refer to that you
can and so I'm gonna be going into more
detail into code than some of the
previous speakers so sometimes it's good
to see the actual code so deep learning
verse versus machine learning so machine
the deep learning is actually a subset
of machine learning so if we go here you
can see that we have machine learning
and the substance deep learning and then
the subset of that is artificial
intelligence so machine learning is kind
of like what it sounds like machines or
computers are are trying to learn
something that they were not explicitly
programmed for so machines observe a
pattern and attempt to imitate it in
some way so machine learning is often
attempting to take an input data set and
transform it into an output data set so
let me show you some examples with
and input data and output data set so
these are all examples that you would
use machine learning or even deep
learning to try to figure out so if you
have pictures of a cat you have the
input is pixels and then the output
would be a presence or absence of a cat
so you input the pixels and the output
of the algorithm would be whether or not
there's a cat there and the next one
would be you could input movies you
liked into the algorithm and they don't
output movies you may like so these are
just to some different possible use
cases you would input words and then an
output whether those words indicated
that the person was happy or sad and
then you would input weather sensor data
and the output would be the probability
of rain so these are all supervised
machine learning tasks and the machine
learning algorithm is attempting to
imitate the pattern between two data
sets in such a way that it can take use
one data set to predict the other data
set so now I'm gonna give you a summary
of how machine learnings would do that
and how a deep learning algorithm would
do that let's say you have this data set
of pictures and a lot of pictures are
pictures of cats but then some of the
pictures are not cats so how it work is
you would input all these pictures into
into your algorithm and you would also
tell it which pictures were cats and
which pictures are not cats
so the supervised learning algorithm is
going to extract patterns from that data
set after it's learn the patterns we can
show it a picture and algorithm will
hopefully tell us whether the picture is
of a cat or not so it takes all the
information you'll give it and then
hopefully later you can give a picture
of a cat that it hasn't seen before and
it will be able to figure out whether
it's a cat or not so deep learning is a
subset of methods in the machine
learning toolbox that uses artificial
neural networks so let's get into more
details about deep learning oh here
would be an example is this a cat
yes it's a cat so all deep learning and
machine algorithm learning algorithms
are gonna be classified as easy as
either supervised or unsupervised
learning so we take what we know and we
transform into what we don't want to
know so that would be a supervised
learning we have something that we know
to be true and we transform it into what
we want to know so like an example would
be we know that we know that this
picture we know that this is this is a
picture of a cat or maybe not a cat and
we put into the algorithm to find out
what we want to know like whether really
it is a picture of a cat and so the goal
of a supervised learning is is to learn
a function that given a sample of data
and a desired outputs best approximates
the relationship between the input and
the output and the data Oh supervised
learning is done using prior knowledge
of what the output values for our sample
should be like in the cat example we
know that the that the output is either
gonna be cat or not cat or maybe you're
trying to identify handwriting and you
know it's gonna be one of the letters of
the alphabet you know you know the
alphabet you know the that you already
know what the output could be for
supervised learning so for unsupervised
machine learning we don't know what the
output could be we're just import and
putting a list of data points and we put
into the algorithm and then out comes a
list of cluster labels so what we don't
know for sure so the algorithm is trying
to figure out and sort the data but it
doesn't know what the categories that is
trying to soar into so unsupervised
learning groups your data the goal is to
infer a natural structure present within
a set of data points and we put you know
we put in a list of data points so we
get the cluster labels out
so basically an unsupervised learning
algorithm says find patterns in this
data and tell me about them so it's just
trying to figure out some patterns let's
see that was slightly out of order we'll
get back to that slide so in this so
this would become an example of
unsupervised data where you have all
this all these data points and your
algorithm groups them into these
different groups and it basically so the
algorithm basically says hey I need a
scientist I found some structure and
your data it looks like here are some
groups in your data here the groups and
then it's up to the data scientists of
the program or to figure out what the
groups are it doesn't tell you what the
groups are you just kind of have to
figure that out after you see the
group's so the next thing I want to talk
about is parametric vers nonparametric
learning and you know pretty soon we'll
get to some actual code examples so this
will start to make more sense but for
for this you can just kind of imagine a
cloud so with so this is our machine
learning cloud there's two knobs we have
supervised and unsupervised knob and a
parametric and non-parametric so there's
you can kind of switch your algorithm to
be either supervisor and unsupervised
parametric or nonparametric supervision
is about the type of pattern being
learned and parametric ISM is the way
the learning is stored so the two types
parametric and nonparametric parametric
is with a fixed number of parameters and
nonparametric is possibly an infinite
number of parameters so here's kind of
an oversimplification the parametric is
trial and error
and nonparametric is about counting and
probability so you could have you're
just kind of counting and you don't know
how many parameters are there's going to
be a nonparametric so let's do an
example I'm going to go back to this
slide so let's say you're trying to
figure out you have this square and
you're trying to figure out where it
should go in this little toy here
now again this is a pretty simple
example but a some people like a baby
may may just jam it into every hole
until they find out where it fits so
that's kind of like parametric learning
now nonparametric learning would be
you're counting the sides of the square
and counting the sides of the hole and
then you kind of figure out where I'll
go on that one so I'm a parametric its
model system to use trial and error like
just trying everything and nonparametric
tends to count to figure out where it
should go but most algorithms are
supervised parametric learning so from
the rest of this talk and the next talk
I'm gonna be talking about supervised
parametric learning and giving you some
examples to go along with that so this
is basically trial and error using knobs
and so there are three steps step one
what we predict so the three steps to
supervised parametric learning is the
first step is predict so for the predict
step you take a your data in this case
we're trying to predict if a sports team
is going to win a game or not
so we input this data like number of
toes on the team number of players
number of fans we put it into our
algorithm which is our machine and then
out comes a prediction so in this case
our prediction is saying that there's a
98% chance given this data that our team
is going to win so step two is going to
be compared to the truth pattern so we
have our prediction which is 90% chance
that the team's gonna win and our truth
pattern is we found out that in real
life they lost the game so 0% chance of
that they're gonna win so we thought we
are original prediction was 98 percent
chance they're gonna win but actually
they lost so we after and so then after
we compare to the truth pattern this is
where we are going to learn the pattern
so learning we're going to just take the
information about how much we were wrong
so we look at how much we missed by
which is 98
sent and we also look at the input data
at the time of the prediction and then
we're gonna turn the knobs so these
knobs will be weights so with the knob
of the win/loss the home away number of
toes number of fans so based on all the
information we're going to adjust the
weights so hopefully the next time the
next iteration of the algorithm we can
be a little closer instead of
ninety-eight percent chance we're gonna
win this and that numbers going to be
lower because we know that in reality
they didn't win with that information
now so now that you kind of know the
basic steps I know it's kind of hard to
understand all that how all that fits
together but now I'm gonna get into some
actual code so hopefully it starts to
make sense what I was talking about with
the predict compare learn so this is a
simple neural network and a neural
network is one or more weights which we
can multiply it by your input data to
make a prediction so it's all about
trying to make a prediction on on the
correct answer based on those weights so
in the example that I gave the
prediction would be whether or not the
team is gonna win a game based on the
input data and the weights so here are
our first few lines of code here we I
start by just hard coding a weight
number now generally your weights are
gonna start as random numbers which
we'll see in the live coding section
later but I'm here it's just a hard code
it's so you can kind of see how how it
works better and we have our neural
network function so we can see that our
neural network function we just pass in
the input and the weights and then it's
gonna set the prediction to input times
weights and it returns the prediction so
it's all about just multiplying inputs
times weights so this diagram what kind
of shows to you how it works you input
the information here multiplies by the
weight of 0.1 and the prediction is for
the percent chance that the team is
going to win
so this next section of code we just
talked about this part right here but
here is our data so we have this array
of number of toes this would be like
average number of toes for each of the
first four games in in the season so
it's kind of a silly example that just
can't bear with me here our input is
just gonna be the first number because
we can only run it on one number at a
time so we're inputting just as eight
point five and then our prediction we
just called the neural network function
which multiplies the input times the
weight and we get out the prediction so
it inputs so we have the eight point
five times the weight so our prediction
is that it's going there's an 85% chance
their team is going to win so we can see
that the prediction is the input times
the weight here so let's talk more about
what the input data is so an input data
is a number recorded in the real world
somewhere so it's usually something
that's easily knowable like in the
example average number of toes it could
be today's temperature it could be
yesterday stock price so it's just some
we're gonna input some data that we can
see in the real world and then we are
going to make a prediction so a
prediction is what the neural network
tells us given our input data so like
given today's temperature we I think the
network thinks there's a zero percent
chance that people are gonna wear
swimsuits today or maybe given yesterday
stock price
there's today's stop stock price is
gonna be a hundred 10.3 or something
like that or a given this many number of
toes this team is going to win the game
so that would be the the prediction and
then the network learns through trial
and error so in that example is just it
only went through at one time so in a in
a real neural network which we will get
to and I'll show you a network with a
lot of iterations every time it runs
through the code it updates the weight
and updates the air
and it keeps it running through the code
over and over to to learn so it first
it's going to try to make a prediction
then it sees whether it was too high or
too low and then finally it changes the
weight up or down to predict more
accurately the next time it sees the
same input so so far we've seen we've
seen the network making a prediction so
remember the three steps were a
prediction and then comparing and then
learning so we still need to I still
need to show you how you would compare
it to the truth pattern and learn and
I'll get to that in a minute but I'm
going to show you one another example
before I get to the compare and learn so
here I'm gonna show you a neural network
with multiple inputs and outputs so the
first example there was just one input
and one output in this example we're
gonna have three inputs so be like the
number of toes per player the win-loss
record number of fans will be the inputs
we're inputting all those things into
the network and then we're outputting
the percentage of her players whether or
not the team is gonna win and whether or
not the team is sad so this is just kind
of to show that I started with showing a
very simple network but they can get
more complex you can have any number of
inputs you want and you can be trying to
predict multiple things you don't know
just you have to predict one thing for
the inputs you can predict multiple
things so here's all the code I mix I'm
gonna kind of zoom in so you can see the
different sections so first we're going
to talk about the weights so before we
just inputted one number for the weight
but now that we have multiple inputs and
multiple predictions we have to have a
matrix so a matrix is just an array of
arrays basically so you can see the
first line is the know is the the
weights for number of people hurt second
line number of people that if we won or
lost
and then percentage of sat and then for
a kind of each column we have the
weights for the number of toes what the
win ratio is and the number of fans so
then our neural net
it looks almost exactly the same as
before remember before we just multiply
the input times of weights and that's
what we're doing now except we have this
fancy function vector matrix
multiplication before we are just
multiplying one number by another number
now we're multiplying a vector which is
an array by a matrix which is an array
of arrays and so we need an extra some
extra code to make it so you can
multiply a vector by a matrix and we'll
see then a little bit here so this is
our information what we're passing our
this is our input data for the first
four games but for our input we're just
going to take the first number of each
array so we're just going to do kind of
one game at a time and so here's an
example of what it would look like for
what we're passing in our EMPA data and
then we have all these predictions that
kind of come out of the network so I
talked to talk about the vector matrix
multiplication function I'm not going to
go into this and and great DTL is just a
way to multiply a vector by a matrix but
in real and this function uses this
weighted sum function but in real life
you're probably never gonna write these
functions yourself because most people
are going to use numpy so numpy gives
you just extra extra functions to do
math like multiplying matrices and func
matrices and vectors so if you it's this
line right here from our neural network
and numpy is gonna be like this and when
I do my life coding I'm actually gonna
use numpy so you'll see how that works
so this dot dot here
that's a numpy function and this just
means multiply the input by weights and
then we get the answer into our
prediction here okay so at the end of
our network we just set our prediction
to equal the return value of our neural
network and we can print our predictions
so you can see here here are predictions
that we printed out based on this
work here so if you if we go over here
you can kind of see everything on the
screen at once and then down here what
you can see the prediction so that first
and you can see how the math is
calculated and so our hurt prediction
was 0.55 so we think there's a probably
55% of players may be hurt 98% chance of
winning and a 97% chance that people are
sad on the team so we can predict three
things at once so the next thing I want
to talk about is error and gradient
descent so this the green descent is
used while training a machine learning
model and it's an optimization algorithm
that tweaks its parameters iteratively
to minimize a given function to its
local minimum so in other words it
allows us to calculate both the
direction and the amount that we should
change our weights so we reduce our
error so the whole point of our neural
network is trying to get our error to
zero so our grading descent which will
see the code later and it's pretty
simple it helps us figure out which
direction we should move our weights and
how much we should move our weight so
when we calculate the error it goes down
is just a way to every time we run the
the code every iteration we're gonna use
our great descent function to get our
weights to the right spot so our error
goes to zero so we talked about
supervised parametric learning in the
three steps we talked about so but so
far you've only seen predict but now I'm
going to show you how to the second two
steps the compare to truth pattern and
learning the pattern so for this step
two is compared to the truth pattern to
measure the air we determine how far our
prediction is from our goal prediction
and then step three learn the pattern it
takes our air and tells each weight how
it can change to reduce it so the whole
point is trying to figure out which
weights
are impacting our air so we can reduce
our air to zero and by time when our air
is zero that shows us that our weights
are accurate because there's no air so
now I'm going to show you pressing this
button here hopefully you'll change
slides this is second oh wait okay
so learning is adjusting our weight to
reduce the air to zero so that's what
we're trying to do to actually that's
what our learning is actually doing so
here is our one iteration of gradient
descent now in a real example you could
have like hundreds of iterations or
thousands of iterations and when I get
to the live coding I'll show you one
with a lot of iterations but let's just
take it one iteration at a time so first
we get our weight and our alpha and our
alpha is the simplest way to prevent
over correcting our weight updates so
sometimes the goal is to get our air to
zero but sometimes instead of our air
going down it will start going up so
alpha is something that's going to help
it to always go down and go in the right
direction and you'll see later how that
fits into our code it's kind of trial
and error for what alpha you're gonna
use but it's usually a multiple of ten
so you would start with maybe point zero
one then you could try point one and
then you maybe try one and just try to
see which one is gonna make your air go
down instead of up and so let's see and
then our neural network is the same as
before we'll just input x weight and
here's the diagram so our input the data
goes here goes through a weight and then
we out comes our prediction of our win
prediction so now we are going to take
we we're gonna do our prediction step so
we pass in our information you can see
there's only a few things different here
which their goal prediction and error so
we didn't talk about air in our last
code but that's very important because
we're trying to get our air to zero
so right here we see that we have our
number of toes eight point five just
like before our input is our number of
toes now our goal prediction is our
winter loss binary which is a 1 means
that the number one means that they won
the game so our goal prediction is 1 so
we think that with the input of 8.5 the
goal prediction is one that we won the
game so we do our friction just like the
floor with our neural network we
multiply the input times the weight and
then our error is gonna equal the
prediction - goal prediction square so
this is prediction - goal prediction is
the raw air it's it's how much we
predict it was going to happen - what we
thought was gonna happen and then the
reason why we square it it forces the
raw air to be positive by multiplying by
itself so it's a negative prediction a
negative air wouldn't make sense so when
we square it's always positive and also
has the added benefit of making large
errors larger and small errors smaller
which actually helps our neural network
to go quicker to the correct to the
correct thing by squaring it like that
so if we run our neural network we do
the 8.5 times 0.1 we get the 0.85 but
then our air ends up being zero point
zero to three
okay so then we have our Delta so this
is the compare step we're gonna
calculate our know Delta and the Delta
is how much this node missed so that's
the raw air prediction - goal prediction
so we need to know how much the node
missed so we can calculate and we can
kind of put it into our output so we
know we know we missed by negative 0.15
because our prediction was eight point
eight five and our goal prediction was
once 0.85 minus 1 is negative 0.15 so
wait Delta this is kind of what this is
where the gradient descent happens so
you can see it's actually a pretty
simple line of code it's how much this
way cause the network to miss so we want
to find out we know that our we miss but
how much do we miss we just use the
weight Delta which is this the input
times Delta gives us the weight Delta
and we're trying to figure out how much
to update the weight because what we're
trying to change the weight on every
iteration now this actually does three
good things for us it helps us with
stopping negative reversal and scaling
so stopping it's the first effect on our
peer error caused by multiplying it by
our input so just imagine you're
listening to music or you're trying
you're playing music on your computer or
you're trying to play music and you have
speaker so you turn up the speaker's all
the way but music still isn't coming out
because you forgot to hit play on your
computer so this will kind of be an
example of stopping where it kind of
addresses in our neural network so if
our input is zero like you've got to
press play on your computer it will
force the weight Delta to also be zero
so we don't learn when our input is zero
because there's nothing there's nothing
to learn and so moving it makes no
difference then negative reversal when
our input is positive moving our weight
upward makes the prediction move upward
but if our input is negative
then all of a sudden our weight changes
directions now we only want our weight
to go in one direction so when our input
is negative then moving our weight up
makes the prediction go it goes down we
don't want that so multiplying our Delta
by our input will reverse the sign of
our weight Delta in the event that our
input is negative so this is the
negative reversal this ensures our
weight moves in the correct direction
the scaling is just when we multi Mew
multiply things together
it's gently it's either gonna get a lot
bigger or a lot smaller if the number is
less than zero so this is this is good
because we want our we want our weight
Delta two we want big ears to be really
big and small to be really small and
alpha is gonna help it so it doesn't go
out of control so we don't want it to
get too big that's why we have the Alpha
which it will just about to talk about
here but first we can see how the weight
Delta it kind of gets applied to the
weight here of negative 1.25 okay so now
we're getting towards the end of this we
are going to update the weight so when
it says weight - equals that just means
weight equals who wait - wait Delta
times alpha and so this this allowed
we're gonna multiply the weight Delta
times the weight or we're gonna do
weight - the weight Delta and we
multiply it by the Alpha to control how
fast the network learns because it can
like a second it can update weights too
aggressively but the Alpha is going to
remember the Alpha in this case was 0.2
zero one so it makes it so the weight
doesn't get update is quick quickly and
so it doesn't get too out of control so
in this case the new weight is zero
point one one - 75
so what we're actually getting toward
the end of our the first part of the
talk I know this is kind of a lot of
information all at once especially if
you're kind of new to deep learning so
my hope is in this far part of the talk
I gave you some like good foundations
and background knowledge so when we get
to the set
part of the talk it will you'll be able
to understand how all goes together so
in the second part of the talk I'm
basically we're gonna use everything
we've learned but we're gonna use a a
real problem and I'm gonna live code a
full neural network complete with
iteration so you'll be able to see how
the weight updates you'll be able to see
how the air updates you'll you'll be
able to see in the output of the the
neural network how the air is going to 0
and hopefully all these things we've
kind of talked about these 16 for the
first time we'll start to make more
sense when you see how it all works in
an actual neural network so we'll also
in the second part of talk talk more
about the deep learning part of this so
so far I have even talked about why it's
called deep learning but that's
something else we'll be talking about
I'm glad to see so many people decide to
come back to part 2 of my talk so this
is where I'll be pulling it all together
what we were talking about in the first
talk and hopefully a lot of things will
start to make a lot of sense once you
see a full neuro network based on trying
to solve a problem let's let's get into
it first of all I'm going to explain the
problem so this is a problem we're gonna
try to solve with a neuro network and
it's kind of it's it's a real-world
problem but it's a simplified real-world
problem so we have enough time to get
through everything and so you can
understand all the components of it so
the problem so you have to imagine a
scenario so imagine this situation where
you go to a country you've never been to
before and you see a stoplight and you
don't know there's three lights but you
don't know which configure the
configuration of lights means to walk in
which configuration of lights mean to
stop so since your since you're a
programmer and a data scientist you
decide you want to collect some data so
you just sit there and watch and you
observe whether people stop or walk so
after a little while you you collect
this information so you can see this is
the first stoplight within that
configuration of lights with the two on
the side on and the middle one off
people stop and then you see this people
walked
in the the second configuration of
lights and then the third was just this
one on a person was stopping so you're
trying to figure out which configuration
means walk and stop but this isn't quite
enough information so you keep looking
and you collect all this information
here and so we're trying to we we
collected the information of what we
know and what we want to know so what we
know is the configuration of the
stoplights what we want to know is
whether they mean to walk or stop so
we're gonna use this data and see if our
neural network that we're going to
develop can figure out which
configuration of lights means to walk or
stop now this is a simple example so
hopefully you can kind of already see a
pattern that the the middle light is
perfectly correlated to whether you
should walk or stop and actually the
left and right light don't have anything
to do with whether you can walk walk or
stop so when we develop our neural
network we're not going to tell it that
information we're gonna see if our
neural network can learn on its own that
the middle light is perfectly correlated
to the walk and stop data so to make a
neural network we cannot just put in
these notes or this picture here so we
have to convert it to numbers so this is
how we're gonna convert our street light
data to numbers so we're gonna make if
the light is on it's a 1 if the light is
on or if it's off it's a 0 so you can
kind of see how these correspond to each
other so we've got this new data set and
we're going to use it to create a neural
network to solve it so I'm gonna go over
to my code editor here now this is
something called Google collab and
Google collab a lot it's basically like
an online code editor for Jupiter
notebook so if you got I don't know if
you're familiar with Jupiter notebook
but it's used a lot for a deep learning
and machine learning and this is an
online version so you don't have to have
anything installed on your computer and
so it's
and make things makes things a lot
simpler when you're testing things out
here so I'll zoom in a little bit more
so this is where I'm going to start
typing code if you want to follow along
you can or you can just look up at the
screen but the first thing we're gonna
do is import numpy as NP you know maybe
old okay that's okay you got you guys
can see that okay so before we didn't
use numpy but now we're gonna use numpy
and that's gonna help with our
multiplication remember before I showed
you that vector matrix multiplication
function we're not gonna need that
because numpy has that built in and
that's the only thing we're gonna import
the rest of it's just gonna be straight
Python so now we're gonna have our
weights array and I'm going to do MP dot
array and MP dot array means it it's a
numpy array and this allows us to do
special operations with it like the
vector matrix multiplication and stuff
like that so a lot of neural networks
the weights are gonna start off randomly
and so I thought this would be a cool
chance for some audience participation
and I'm going to see if you guys can
give me some numbers they have to be
between negative one and one and so give
me a decimal point between negative one
and one so it does anybody want to call
out a number for our first weight okay
how about zero point seven and then we
another it has to be between negative
one and one anybody else have another
number okay and then our final number
okay so this is just a fun way to get
random numbers so you can see later that
it kind of doesn't matter what you start
your weights out as your networks gonna
be able to learn and get to the correct
weight with just random weights so the
next line is the Alpha and we talked
about that a little bit before the Alpha
helps make sure your network doesn't get
out of control
and the whole point of the network is to
get our air to zero and but sometimes
the air can start going up instead of
down to zero and the Alpha will make
sure it doesn't go go out of control
like that so now we're going to import
our data that we collected so it's going
to MP dot array now I'm going to be just
me this is going to be a vector or a
matrix so that's an array of arrays and
I'm just going to be typing in this
information I've had some notes here but
this is directly from the other slide of
what this is going to look like so this
is kind of the sometimes that the
tedious part of machine learning and
data science is like dealing with the
data and inputting data but it's just a
part of it is actually just trying to
put everything into the network and
usually you're not going to be having to
type in the data you're usually going to
get it from some other source so it may
not be you typing in every single number
in the data set let's see
and you at some point you may see me
type something and wrong that let's it's
obvious that's wrong so feel feel let me
know like if I spell like a variable
wrong or something like that okay so if
we go back to our data this should look
just like when we typed in right here
and now our next piece of information is
our walk verse stop array so this is
again information we collected in the
real world in this example and we're
gonna do another MP array and then pass
in the array which is going to be 0 1 0
1 1 0 so again that's the the walk verse
actually to go back a slide so this is
any time it's 0 or stop is 0 1 is walk
okay there we go and then we can start
with our iteration so in the last
example before the break I showed you a
single iteration but in this example
we're going to do an iteration of 40 so
I'm going to do 4 iteration and range 40
now like I had said previously and
sometimes you could have hundreds or
thousands of iterations and the whole
point is that every time we go through
an iteration the air gets closer and
closer to zero and the way you figure
out how many iterations to do is just to
try on air so from from preparing for
the talk and other experiences kind of
trying out different things I found out
that in 40 iterations this network
should be able to get the air to 0 but
there's no there's not really a magic
number you just have to try different
things and see the result and see how
long it takes to get to 0 so now we are
going to have a variable called air for
all
and it's gonna be set to zero so we need
to figure out the air because the whole
point is get the air to zero so we have
to something to collect the air so we're
going to be adding to that air later and
now I may have another iteration for row
index and range and then it's gonna just
be the length of the stop verse walk
array so we're going to do something for
every element in this walk verse top
array and the number of elements in the
walk for stop array is also in the
number of arrays or vectors in the
streetlights array so we're gonna do
something for each one that you'll see
in a second here
so in our last example just like in a
last example we need an input in a goal
prediction so this is going to be pretty
similar and like the input is going to
be from the streetlights array and I'm
gonna put the the row index and then the
goal prediction is going to be from the
walk for stop array and that's gonna be
the row index so you'll see we're gonna
go through we're gonna iterate through
each one because this array corresponds
to this number the second race
corresponds to the second number to the
third rate corresponds to the third
number okay what what part okay well I'm
the space after what
oh stop verse walk I said definitely no
like is this we're talking about oh okay
thank you I don't know I was looking at
for summer I was thinking there's a
spelling year so it's like what spelled
wrong so yeah thanks for pointing that
out
so this is a this is an example what I
was talking about I'm gonna make some
mistakes but luckily I have the audience
seat or two to help me fix these
mistakes here okay so now we have our
input in our goal prediction we can make
our prediction so let me see if I can
can you guys still see down at the
bottom of the screen there okay so our
prediction now if you remember before
when we add our prediction in the first
part of the talk I showed that we called
our neural network function in our
neural network function just multiply
the input times the weight so instead of
creating a neural network function we're
just going to do the input times the
weight but we're gonna use
numpy so this is this dot function just
multiplies input times weights and it
can multiply a vector times a matrix so
we're getting them the prediction the
same ways from before and now we have to
calculate the error was okay there we
can see a little better
the error is going to equal prediction -
goal prediction and that's the same as
before so it's how we figure how far
away our prediction was from what we
thought it was going to be is the error
and then also oh yeah one last thing we
have to take that to the power of two so
remember the point of that is to make
sure the air is positive if you square
it it's gonna be a positive number and
then also it makes big errors even
bigger and small errors even smaller and
that's actually something we want
because it can it will get to the
correct and
even faster so now we are just going to
add to our air for all lights let's see
error for all lights and I'm just going
to plus equals error so just but we're
just collecting all the airs into the
air for all lights so we're getting an
air for each one of the walk for stop
array and we're putting them all
together because we want the collective
air to get close to zero as possible and
then we're gonna calculate the Delta and
that's going to be prediction - goal
prediction this is just how far away our
prediction is from our goal prediction
and it's it's considered the raw air
this is the same as before and now we
are going to calculate the weights now
in our previous example the weights
equaled weights
- weight delta x alpha and we're gonna
basically have the same same thing here
but we're gonna instead of creating the
weight Delta variable if you remember
from before we're gonna kind of put it
in line and it's going to be weights
minus alpha so I mean the parentheses
here
time's input so before the wait Delta
was input times Delta and instead of
making that wait Delta variable we're
gonna put it right in line so weights
equals weights minus alpha times input
times Delta so that's the same as before
and now what we're going to just print
out some data so this is actually the
whole code and so I'm going to print out
some data here and then we'll see what
happens
so we're gonna do we're gonna print the
prediction so we want to see the
prediction variable and I'll just do the
string of prediction now I'm going to
use some copying and pasting here the
prediction will do for each of that
iteration but the next you will put in
to this next loop let's see yep that
lines up right oh right here okay thanks
I appreciate that okay so now we have
Waits and waits and then we'll print out
the error and the error okay
so we're about to run this code and see
what happens but before we run the code
I'm going to go back to the slides okay
so this diagram demonstrates what our
network looks like so we have three
inputs and then we pass them through
these weights and then we're gonna get
an output which is the walk for stop
that whether the the output is going to
show whether those inputs mean to walk
or stop so that's the whole point of our
network we're trying to learn from do
these inputs of the light mean to walk
or stop so that's what we're gonna do
here we go I'll just run this code
and it's gonna take a little bit but we
should see if I didn't make any spelling
mistakes we should see some stuff
appearing at the bottom here which is
the data okay so you'll see at the FIR
first the the prediction doesn't really
correspond to anything at first and the
weights are going to be pretty similar
to the weights we pass in at the very
beginning so you can see here you're the
weight so in point six point four
negative point two that's pretty close
to the weights we started with right
here but if we keep going down we did 40
iterations so every time it gets to the
air we're to the next iteration so the
air starts at point three we're trying
to get as close as possible to zero so
if we just keep going down we're not
gonna look at every single iteration
we're gonna just kind of go down to the
bottom and see what we've gotten to okay
so here's the the last the last thing
that we want to look at and if you look
at the prediction this number is very
close to zero then what the second one
is close to one then we have one close
to zero one one zero so if you remember
what this actually is the same as our
stop first walk so we have the stop is
zero one zero one one zero and that's
what the prediction ended up being close
to zero one zero one one zero now that's
not necessarily super exciting because
we actually gave gave the network that
information so of course it's going to
be able to figure that out that
information because we put it right in
the code another thing I just kind of
should've showed you first was the error
this is a number very close to zero it
starts with a three point but then when
you see we this is just like an exponent
that makes it really it's a really small
number very close to zero so and that's
the whole point of our our algorithm is
just trying to get the air to zero so
what's really important to look at is
the weights so if you see the weights
these weights correspond to each light
so the first light the first way is
close to zero the second light is close
to one and the third way is close to
zero
so one means it's perfectly correlated
and zero means it's not correlated at
all at all and if you remember from our
diagram the middle light was perfectly
correlated on whether you should walk or
stop and the the right and left lights
were not correlated at all so there was
no point in the code that we gave the
program that information but somehow it
was able to learn that the middle light
was perfectly correlated and the outer
lights were not correlated at all now in
this example it was something that you
can easily figure out just by looking at
the data which ones correlated but you
can just kind of imagine in a more
complex data set you may not be able to
figure out how the data is correlated
just by looking at it so you use the
exact same type of ideas to make an even
more complex neural network and so you
can actually learn things that that's
not that aren't as easy to just learn
just by looking at the data and so our
network is that our network correctly
identified the middle light by analyzing
the final weight positions of the
network so to like think about how it
identified the correlation it was in the
process of gradient descent each
training example either is gonna assert
up upward pressure or downward pressure
on the weights
so on average there was more upward
pressure for the middle weight and more
downward pressure on the outer weights
so they got to the correct numbers so
this is pretty cool and now I'm going to
show you something even a little a
little more complex so the next part of
the talk instead of live coding I'm
going to show you some code that's
already written that's pretty similar to
the code we already had but I'm gonna
introduce a few more concepts first of
all I want to tell you that some of the
concepts could even be a whole talk to
themselves so I'm gonna do my best to
clegg quickly overview the concepts but
some of the things will you'll just kind
of get a taste of so you can learn more
about on your own
later but the reason why I'm going to
show you one more program is to talk
about the deep part of deep learning so
nothing I've showed you so far is
actually deep so let me a deep refers to
one or more hidden layers between the
input and output layers of a neural
network so if I go to my code here so
our input layer is right here our output
layers right there there's nothing in
between
but if I look we look at this example
this is a true deep neural network
because we ever input layer that looks
the same there's three on the input and
one on the output for layer two but now
there's this middle layer which is a
hidden layer and since there's one or
more hidden layers this is a deep neural
network so we may be wondering why would
you even need a hidden layer if our
other network was able to correctly
predict the correlation between the
lights because we're gonna use the same
example from before so if you remember
the data the middle light was perfectly
correlated with whether you should walk
or stop but if the middle light wasn't
so perfectly correlated our network
would have had a much harder time
figuring out how the how the input was
delayed to the output so like for
instance if our training data look like
this our other network wouldn't have
worked so well if you look at this so
the numbers in red are the the light
information whether the lights are on or
off and the numbers in black are the
stop or walk information so you can see
this first the first three up here means
to walk and we have walk stop stop and
one thing you'll notice is that the
output data is not perfectly correlated
with any of the rows so this is where
you need to have a hidden layer um well
this because since our inputs the data
set does not correlate with our
correlate with our output data set we're
going to use our input data set to
create an intermediate data set that
does have correlation with our output
and this intermediate data set is our
hidden layer
it's almost going to be like two
neuro-networks it's gonna be from layer
zero to layer one is gonna be one
network that runs just like before and
then the so the output to the layer zero
to layer one network will become the
input to the layer 1 to layer 2 network
so let me show you okay so can you guys
see this all right even the back ok so a
lot of this is going to look pretty
similar here we have what we're
importing numpy is MP and then this line
right here just makes we're gonna be
using random numbers in this code and
that line just make sure the random at
seed make sure every time we get random
numbers it's the same random numbers so
a lot of times when you're used to
dealing with neural networks you're
using random numbers for the weights but
to make sure the output is always the
same even though you're using random
numbers you can make sure that every
time the code runs the ramen numbers
were the same nanyem numbers that you
use last time you ran the code and it
helps for like comparing to make sure
the code the results are exactly the
same so this is called a this is an
activation function it's the relu
function we're going to pass our data
into it it's going to return X or return
it's going to return well the data we
passed in if X is more than 0 or return
0 otherwise now this is it's called an
activation function because it activates
some input by returning the input and
deactivates other input by returning 0
this code is going to show a three-layer
neural network and by turning any middle
network off whenever would be negative
we allow the network to sometimes have
the correlation from various inputs and
sometimes not have the correlation so
it's impossible for a two-layer network
to sometimes allow this input to
correlate and sometimes not allow it to
imp correlate so adds more power to
three-layer networks so this sometimes
correlation is important for things to
work correctly and
is one of the areas that like I was
saying could get a whole talk to itself
as activation functions and how they
work and why but I'm just gonna kind of
leave it at that for now and that the
activation is function is important to
make it sometimes correlate and
sometimes not correlated the the relu to
drift function is next and this returns
one when the output is more than zero or
zero otherwise and that's the slope of
our ello function or its derivative and
you'll see later how that's important so
the next to this is just inputting the
data just like we did before we do have
the dot T that's a numpy thing it's the
transpose operator and it just changed
it so you have a matrix which is going
to have like almost like an x and y
coordinate like the so it's a if it's a
three by four matrix the transpose
operator will make it a four by three or
if it's a one by four it'll become a
four by one and when it's when you're
multiplying matrix and a vector it
matters which kind of direction the the
matrix is if that makes sense and so the
Alpha is same before again sometimes you
have to kind of try out different things
to figure out what it's going to work
and the hidden size is four so if we go
back to our diagram you can see that our
middle layer has four nodes so that's
what this hidden size equals for is
there's four nodes and then here is our
weights so okay let me get back to that
code here I accidentally did the
keyboard the mouse shortcut for going
back so if we go to our weights here
before this is where we had the
audience-participation and I had people
shout out different weights but now
we're gonna get truly random weights
because we have a lot more weights this
is going to be a matrix of weights and
the size of the matrix like the matrix
is similar to this this is a matrix
right here up top three by four matrix
and this is going to be a 3 by 4 matrix
and the
is going to be a 4 by1 matrix and each
number in that matrix is going to be
between negative 1 and 0 and the reason
why we have 3 by 4 is because you can
see there's 3 nodes by 4 nodes and we
have 4 nodes by 1 node so the size of
the weights has to correspond to the
input and output layers because you can
kind of you can see that this has
there's a weight between later one and
layer 0 and there's weights between
layer 1 and layer 2 and the size of the
weights have to correspond to those
layers so now we're gonna you can see
we're gonna iterate 60 times and then
we're gonna keep track of the air just
like before we were keeping track of the
air it just called something different
so in this code there's gonna be a lot
of things that are pretty much just like
the code that I just did for the live
coding but the names are slightly
different so layer 0 here this is the
same as the input from before so we're
just getting the first street light
which would be this matrix right here
this vector right here and this is just
a kind of fancy way of saying that we're
gonna get a nested mate a nested array
so instead of instead of an array of
1 0 1 it will be an array of an array of
1 0 1 so they'll just be like it if you
output it it there would be an extra
array on the sides there you go so
the so that just makes the kind of math
work to have an array of arrays but it's
just getting the first array from the
streetlights and then layer one here is
going to be the same as the input and
the same as the prediction from before
or the other network we had one input
and that input had one prediction but in
this neural network it's basically two
neural networks there's two two networks
there's layer 1 to layer there's layer 0
to layer 1 and there's layer 1 to layer
2 so the prediction or output from layer
0 to layer 1 becomes the input from
layer 1 to layer 2 so this layer 1 is
the input and the prediction so just
like before we're always just multi to
get a prediction you always multiply the
input times weights so that's what this
is
it's another numpy function to just
multiply the things that you pass into
that function layer 0 and weight 0 1
that's what you're always doing for your
prediction multiplying inputs times
weights then we run it by the relu
function which will selectively activate
like we talked about before layer 2 is
our output layer and which is the same
as your prediction from before and again
we're just multiplying the input times
the weight so the input is layer 1 and
the weights is weights 1 2 so this is
the same thing we've been doing all
along to get the prediction from the
first stop from the very first code
example this was the neural network we
had a neural network function that just
multiplied weights times input and
that's exactly what we're doing here so
now we have to get our error so our
error is gonna we have our layer 2 error
here and we're gonna calculate that
pretty much just like before but we have
different names so before it was the
era's prediction - goal prediction
squared but now the prediction is that
layer 2 variable the goal prediction is
the getting something from the walk vs.
top array and we square it so air is
always prediction my school prediction
squared
and then we're going to do a plus equal
so we're going to add up all the heirs
together into our layer two error
variable okay so the next thing is our
Delta this is basically exactly like the
the other example so this we have the
layer two so this is just input or wait
a second yeah input minus goal
prediction prediction - school
prediction so layer two mice walk first
stop it's the same as prediction - goal
prediction and remember the goal here is
err attribution it's all about figuring
out how much each weight contributed to
the final error so in our first two
layer neural network we calculate a
delta value a delta variable which told
us how much higher or lower the output
prediction is supposed to be so we're
calculating that in the same way so now
we have how much that we that though we
want the final prediction to move up or
down that's the Delta and now we need to
figure out how much we want each middle
layer layer one node to move up or down
so one thing that's interesting about
this is if we go to our diagram we can
see there's an order later 0 layer 1
layer 2 but in our code we're gonna
calculate layer 2 first and then layer 1
so we're not calculating it in the same
order as you would normally think going
through the let going through the layers
this is another like really big concept
called back propagation let me get some
me this is Uma out so you can see all
the notes I have here so in back
propagation the layer to Delta is back
propagated to the layer 1 Delta and this
is going to give us a weighting of how
much each weight contributed to that
error that's supposed to be in it the
word ear oh it is it's just off the side
of the screen ok so we need some way for
our layer 2 weights to
Packt layer one because we need to
update everything so that's what back
propagation is and so this is another
pretty big concept I mean back
propagation could be a whole talk of its
own but it's all about taking
information from later on in the the
network in passing it back to to the
earlier in the network so it can use
that information when it's making the
calculations and let's see if there's
one more thing we need to talk about so
this is for the layer one Delta here
we're just using this dot function to
multiply layer two Delta by the weights
and we have the transpose operator but
then the final thing is this relu to
derive function so if the relu set the
output to layer one to the layer not one
note to be zero then it didn't
contribute to the air at all so when
this was true we should also set the
Delta of that node to be zero and
multiplying each layer one node by the
relative function accomplishes this the
reloj to the rib is either a one or a
zero depending on whether the later one
value was more than zero or not so now
we're gonna update the weights and we
update the weights just like we did
before so for each weight we are going
to multiply its input value by its
output del Delta and so it's just
weights 1/2 equals weights 1/2
- wait I'm thinking yeah yeah weights
1/2 equals eight weight 1/2 minus alpha
times and then so this is just how we
calculate the weight before where you
multiply the input by the Delta and you
multiply that by the Alpha and then
that's that's just how you update the
weights so again this code is all all
online so you can kind of review it
later like some of the stuff ecstatics
going through a few times to really see
how it all goes together but you'll see
that we're updating
waits in the exact same way as we were
in the other live coding session that we
did so down here this is going to just
make sure that we're only going to print
this information just every once in a
while so every few iterations so when we
run when we run this it's only going to
give the information every few
iterations so I'm just going to run this
right now and I think it had that from
last time I ran it but if the main thing
to look at here is that if we go to the
bottom our error gets very close to zero
so that's the whole point of learning
the learning is trying to get our air as
close as possible to zero now if you
learner before that that means meant
that our weights were correctly we're
making a correct prediction in this case
that it's it's the same now I'm kind of
getting close to to the conclusion of
kind of why all this matters so what I
mean there's probably we could probably
talk about this code for a few more
hours to explain it every little part
like the back propagation and and the
weights but I kind of want to do kind of
step back a little bit and give kind of
an an overview of the point of why we
create intermediate data sets that have
correlation so I go back over here okay
so consider this image of this hand
written for it's kind of blown up it's
supposed to be it's supposed to look
like the number four and if you if we
had a data set of a bunch of images of
handwritten digits and they were all
labeled like zero to nine if we want to
treat a train a neural network to take
the pixel values from this image and
predict that this was a four hour two
layer neural network would have never
been able to do it so there's just
there's no individual pixel in this and
this year so there's no individual pixel
that perfectly correlates with whether
it's a
for or not just like in our second
example that I just went over there is
no light combination that perfectly
correlated with Walker stop so there's
there's only different configurations of
pixels that correlate with whether or
not this is a four so this is the
essence of deep learning if I go to the
next slide you'll see how this would
work with kind of multiple layers where
deep learning is all about creating
intermediate datasets or layers where
each node in an intermediate layer
represents the presence or absence of a
different configuration of inputs so in
this way no pixel has two perfectly
correlate with whether or not it's a
four or not instead we have these middle
layers that they attempt to identify
different configurations of pixels that
may or may not correlate with the four
so we go through a lot of different
layers and finally it finds which later
correlates if I find a configuration of
pixels that correlates with whether it's
a floor or not and then it outputs that
this is a four so the presence of many
four like configurations would then give
the final layer the information or
correlation it needs to correctly
predict whether the digit is a four so
we can take our three layer network and
continue to stack many many more layers
on some networks even have hundreds of
layers and each neuron plays its part in
detecting different configurations of
input data so you could start with like
we started with these input of three
layers but the hidden layers could get
bigger and bigger and bigger until it
finally has what it needs to correctly
predict the output layer so I'm hoping
that just kind of seeing this for
example helps you kind of see how how
adding additional layers can help you
get the final prediction where you don't
need just like our stoplight example you
don't need the perfect correlation to
figure out the final answer you can make
other layers and other layers after that
that finally get the correlation to get
the final
sir so I'm getting kind of close to the
end of the talk here so I'm hoping you
just buy this talk you got a good
introduction to deep learning and neural
networks and you saw by the examples how
we were able to write a neural network
they actually learned what we're trying
to learn and then I also hope you
understand how hidden layers can can
give your neural network even extra
power to figure out things that would
not have normally figured out so yeah
thank you for coming to the talk and I'm
open for questions right now
[Applause]